the correct way i get real i'm so
sensitive what's your poker face like
jason uh i have one i just shut off and
i look like i'm going to punch you in
the face
oh really yeah it happened at a show
it's very effective yeah i did a show at
skank fest my the jason ella show live
in front of a live audience and a
comedian a comedian that i really like
that i haven't met told a dude to come
up to the stage and say hey you guys
suck you're not funny
and uh and the guy came down and said it
and i was like
i'm not
i'm like i thought we were doing good
and then i'm burying myself right now
and then the guy next to me dan soda
goes wait that guy got told by shane
gillis to say that and i'm like wait
shane gillis thinks i suck oh that's way
worse than a random dude
and they're all joking about it saying
hey don't worry we discovered the
culprit but people dm me after the show
came out they could tell like i shut off
and i was like
i i really liked that guy and i thought
that the show was doing well i thought i
was like you know what i'm pretty
talented but to know that i suck is
pretty
he said come on man i don't think you're
not funny at all like he if it's a bit
that it's right if that happened to you
you would shut down i know you bobby
yeah i did crying i know i left the
venue and there were people like man
alice what a show and i was like thank
you oh
and i walked all the way back to my
hotel like shut off my wife when i go
back to the room like what i'm like
doesn't matter just someone oh jason
i've been there i've been there i've
been there i've been there don't worry
about it it's like the [ __ ] that guy
yeah and i noticed that the other guys
didn't get touched by it and i was like
you're touchy
everybody else on stage was like hey you
know gillis and yeah right on i was like
still like how do i is it me that sucked
which part
did i do that made it oh my god better
myself oh i love a good downward spiral
yes
yeah it's funny it's all in here with us
right it's just we we
we assume things and our minds go out of
control and all of a sudden it's a
whirlwind and you're out you're [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean so i'm sorry i
got booed off a stage in front of 20 000
people boom like 20 years ago
something's thrown out no things throw
twenty thousand people throwing
bottles at me i just
like you know how like
a single team not funny it's not a
single tear came down my face like this
and i just walked off stage didn't you
say bye i didn't say bye i remember
seeing a replay and i was
on stage going i did it i was so i was
bombing so hard i started mumbling on
stage i started going
and i couldn't even get a word out damn
you just left and i just left the stage
but check you check it out bro they
still [ __ ] paid me dog what's up
that's not a very good thing that's a
terrible energy
yeah that was not there was no better
ending no that was no reason
after and you crushed it no they i got
paid off what's up i'd say yeah he's
right no the next night i did the same
show
but i rearranged the lineup
and then i killed
wait the lineup told the jokes in a
different lineup and no it's the lady i
followed i couldn't follow her
it was leslie jones
wait if somebody's was she really funny
or really unfunny
she
destroyed me
leslie jones is very funny
oh so yeah don't go out after stop
okay
i'm just starting to get into it yeah
learning stand up you're in yeah yeah
yeah it's the most hardest thing i've
ever done in my life and i fight like i
fought a
like 300 pound man on steroids once
and i was more nervous the other day
going out
uh
in front of 500 people than
anywhere near the bit right when [ __ ]
when i could tell shane calm was like
i'm gonna knock you out and i was like
oh
this is terrifying
it's more scared when i they said you're
gonna love this guy i was like
probably won't i mean [ __ ] but jake can
you listen to can you think of it in
this way
you're on stage right and you have guys
like was it samurail or mark norman
would you say was it there
the comments at the comic the comics
that were there it was shane
oh no oh if you know [ __ ] shane and uh
uh dan soder dan soldier
so just those three alone right guys
just those three alone
they're the best comics on planet earth
they are heavy and you are with them
right you're
in the same group with them that's why
so what does that say about you
you're you belong there you should have
been it's not a fluke i needed somebody
to say that because i was like yeah
those are all heavy hitters which means
when he says this show isn't funny it's
me no i'm making it no no
no no that's what i thought he has done
our podcast before he's banned
we have a shitless band now
my little sensitive australian friend
over here wow right
[ __ ] ban him write that down write it
down my bad dude
wow yeah off with his head this is
the biggest thing that's ever happened
yeah bro i have power dude